(rock music)
- Right on the fingers.
- I'm not thrilled with this smell.
- Oh, that's horrible, whatever that is.
- Twizzlers.
100%
Nope.
- Root beer.
- That's bubble gum.
- It's nail polish and Twizzlers.
- It's glue?
- Oh!
- What kind of glue?
- It smells very familiar,
yet I don't sniff glue.
- I sniffed a lot of glue.
- Uh...
(blows raspberry)
(light orchestral music)
- I know we're gonna get this one.
- Oh.
- I'm not gonna get this one.
- Smells like some kind of plant.
- I like it. I like it a lot.
- Sweet? Starbursty?
- Lemon grass?
- Cucumber melon. Bath and Body Works.
- Oh, like late 90's Bath
and Body Works smell?
- Yeah. The goos that
ladies put on their hands.
- Lady goos.
(laughs)
- No.
- Dirt.
(ding)
- Done.
(sighs)
- Dirt.
- Is it dirt?
(laughs)
- Oh shit!
- Dirt smells good!
(jazzy music)
- I'm not ready for this.
- This smells bad from far away.
- It smells like shit, so it's -
(sighs)
(gags)
- I don't like that one.
- That is disgusting.
- Terrible.
- Give me another.
- I'm mad at you for that one.
But it smells like pizza.
(ding)
- A burnt Italian restaurant.
- It's like dead pizza.
- It smells a little bit like gasoline.
- This is like when you pick
your belly button and smell it.
- Smells like my old sofa.
- I might throw up if I smell that again.
- Burnt milk.
- Cheese?
- Dirty socks?
Parmesan cheese?
Piercing holes?
- It's hair on fire. That's what it is.
- Is it a body part?
- Burnt hair and burnt milk.
- Done.
- Easy.
- You don't even need to tell us.
- It's pizza?
- Is it pizza?
Why does pizza smell like garbage?
- Yeah!
- Oh, she's right?
- Oh, great!
- Dude, you are so good at this.
- I have a really great nose, y'all.
- Wow.
- That makes me not want
to eat pizza ever again.
- I would not eat a pizza
that smelled like that.
(laughs)
- You guys are so weird.
- [Voiceover] Gavon, was
today a good day or a bad day?
(groans)
(game show music)
- It was a bad day.
- [Voiceover] Why?
- David Bowie died over the weekend,
and everybody's still
pretty bummed out about it.
But, the plus side, all
of the memorializing,
people had remembered that
he had a stellar film career,
including Labyrinth.
So everybody go watch Labyrinth.
RIP Goblin King.
(techno music)